ils sont des dizaines de milliers massés
dans le froid aux portes de la turquie
mais elle reste fermée
nous demandons à la turquie de nous
aider dit ceci rien de nous laisser
entrer plutôt que de les laisser passer
la turquie distribuer des tentes et des
repas du côté syrien de la frontière où
elle les considère en sécurité la
turquie accueille déjà quelques deux
millions cinq cent mille réfugiés
syriens et se fait reprocher par l'union
européenne de ne pas faire assez
d'efforts pour stopper le flot de
migrants qui quittent ses côtes pour
échouer en grèce voici ce que cette
nouvelle vague de réfugiés fuient une
offensive du régime syrien appuyé par
l'aviation us et des milices chiites
libanais afghane irakienne pour
reprendre le contrôle d'al est la
deuxième ville du pays
ces images mises en ligne par des
activistes montrerait un bombardement
russe dans la région d'alep impossible
pour nous de vérifier de façon
indépendante ces informations
même chose pour ces images qui montrent
une fillette terrorisée
alors que des médecins tente de la
soigner j'étais avec ma mère mes frères
et mes soeurs dit elle un avion nous a
tiré dessus une la maison s'est
effondrée mais c'est pas ce qui est
arrivé aux autres alors que human rights
watch publié un rapport accusant
l'aviation russe d'employer des bombes à
fragmentation
banny dans la communauté internationale
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
de passage en turquie s'est dit
consterné par les souffrances provoquées
par les bombardements russes
miclo h 30 nous sommes depuis quelques
jours non seulement consternée et
choquée dans la souffrance des dizaines
de milliers de personnes à cause des
bombardements russes at-elle dit
chouette
l'entrée en scène de la russie aux côtés
du régime syrien a permis à ce dernier
de reprendre du terrain aux différentes
factions rebelles sur plusieurs fronts
selon nos informations plus d'une
dizaine de groupes rebelles paniqués
tentent maintenant de se regrouper sous
une même bannière unifiée l'armée dalet
mais pour conserver le contrôle d'une
partie d'alep
il pourrait bien être trop tard ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada beyrouth